[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre numéro des diapos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
6 avril
un rendez vous pour les plus gourmands
ce week end le traditionnel marché des
terroirs de voisins-le-bretonneux
revient pour une nouvelle édition 23
exposants pour régaler les papilles des
visiteurs jusqu'au dimanche 8 avril à
notre invité nous en parlera les
artistes locaux à l'honneur avec
l'exposition art talent un concours
d'arts visuels organisé par la ville de
guyancourt qui regroupe différentes
techniques de la peinture à la sculpture
en passant par la photographie c'est à
découvrir jusqu'au 29 avril une journée
pour apprendre l'écocitoyenneté à magny
les hameaux enquêter sur une scène de
crime à prendre les premiers secours et
s'intéresser à l'écologie et au droit
des enfants
notre rendez-vous junior mélanie poker
nous dira ce qu'est un éco citoyen avec
les beaux jours qui reviennent c'est
aussi le moment de se remettre au sport
et aux activités en plein air les 7 et 8
avril la ligne de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines ouvre grand ses
portes pour un week-end de découverte
entrée gratuite animations nouveautés et
places offertes
l'occasion de découvrir ou de
redécouvrir le lieu le responsable
communication nous en a parlé dans notre
journal
c'est la plus grande et la plus belle
île de loisirs d'île de france 600
hectares de deux pleine nature avec le
plus grand plan d'eau d'île de france
également d'accord et vous pouvez
trouver toutes sortes d'activités pour
tous depuis le plus jeune âge jusqu'au
là je veux plus avancée pour les
sportifs les amoureux de la nature
pour les amateurs de sensations fortes
en avant pour tous dans l'ancienne
piscine à vagues qui est devenu
aujourd'hui un espace événementiel de
sky part qui nous a rejoint l'an dernier
et qui propose une multitude d'activités
hyper novatrices comme du pilotage de
drones et là en l'occurrence sûr il y a
skymark est le premier club de pilotage
de drones de reis course
une nuit consacrée aux arts martiaux à
plaisir ce samedi 7 avril dès 20h30 deux
heures de spectacle et de démonstration
au palais des sports judo capoeira
karaté boxe anglaise et française
les arts martiaux possède une grande
diversité de pratiques et c'est cette
variété qui est mise à l'honneur avec
cette première édition organisée par le
fondateur de l'homme qui dosent ce sera
aussi l'occasion de découvrir cette
nouvelle discipline de kido c'est moi
qui les créent ça fait 45 ans moi je
pratique les arts martiaux
c'est une synthèse des arts martiaux du
monde s'il ya plus d'une centaine d'arts
martiaux qui sont totalement synthétiser
sur les mêmes principes et donc ça
permet de passer d'un martial un autre
est de créer un art martial à part
entière aussi quelque part donc
l'intérêt c'est d'insister sur
l'autodéfense d'insister sur l'aspect
martial mais aussi sur les sports de
combat très proche des mma mais mma
éducatif produits gourmands production
artisanale le marché des terroirs de
voisins-le-bretonneux revient ce week
end pour une nouvelle édition
un rendez vous devenu incontournable
organisé par le centre alfred de vigny
on en a parlé avec notre invité
mélanie poker aux moyens techniques nous
sommes au centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux les équipes se
préparent pour la 12e édition du marché
des terroirs et nous avons parlé de ce
rendez vous gourmand avec pierre rey
référent communication du centre bon
jour pour jour alors le marché des
terroirs ça commence ce vendredi 6 avril
jusqu'à dimanche
de nombreux exposants sont attendus je
pourrais te retrouver on va retrouver 23
exposants cette année avec cinq nouveaux
des paniers gourmands
va y avoir des les huiles essentielles
d'été du monde de choses à découvrir
et parmi eux alors donc du coup parmi
les exposants les 23 exposants que vous
en avez cité quelques-uns nouveau et
parmi les anciens alors qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve vraiment quand on parle de
terroir qu'est ce que c'est vraiment il
ya déjà des vignerons des vignerons dont
il ya un vigneron alsacien qui vient
régulièrement depuis le début de marché
des vins de beaujolais
il va y avoir de la charcuterie corse
[Musique]
où
un charcutier qui va vendre son bout
d'un excellent boudin que tout le monde
n'en raffole et chaque année viennent
via se ravitailler il y aura des
fromages
enfin beaucoup de un petit peu de sucre
est aussi peut-être un vrai tueur un peu
de sucre et le lait des fruits confits
puis d'autres choses
découvrir apprécier pour le vent si ça à
consommer avec modération bien sûr
et donc il y aura des produits régionaux
dont vous l'avez cité notamment à que le
vin alsacien donc bien connu dans nos
frontières métropolitaine mais il ya
aussi des produits du monde du rhin
des produits du monde il y aura un
espagnol
et
dont je suis le
le vigneron représentants dudit domaine
des jolis vins d'altitude de montagne
et en quelles sont ses particularités a
souvent espagnol la particularité du vin
on est très sûr le fruit
beaucoup de fraîcheur les vins sont sont
assez naturel parce qu'il n'y a pas deux
il ya pratiquement pas de traitement de
la vigne
ça c'est très important donc
on a des cépages français mais on a un
cépage principal qui s'appelle la mantia
mn cia qui est
qui est un très beau ces pages
famiglia avec des cas bermudes
un truc à berne et sir d'accord donc à
découvrir en tout cas alors justement ce
rendez vous et le marché des terroirs
c'est devenu incontournable à voisins le
bretonneux cela a toujours autant de
succès tout à fait bien sûr du succès
on a aussi des astuces des animations on
a une association
de voitures anciennes
entre autres qui viennent qui vient le
dimanche voilà qui vient le dimanche
matin et qui va exposer toutes ces
belles voitures
ancien avec entre autres des vies si
noir durant leurs voitures qui vont
arriver là la voiture sur le parking
un régal des papilles mais aussi un
régal des yeux du coup avec les voitures
donc merci en tout cas pierre rennes où
le rendez vous est pris ce vendredi 6
avril à quel moment ce qu'on peut
commencer à arriver
vous pouvez commencer à arriver dès le
vendredi dès 17 heures vendredi après
midi 17 heures jusqu'à 20 heures
après on a samedi de 9 heures à 20
heures et dimanche de 9 heures à 13
heures c'est noté merci beaucoup en tout
cas donc pour les gourmands et les
curieux rendez vous dès ce vendredi 6
avril sur le parking
bricorama rue aux fleurs à voisins le
bretonneux et comme toujours les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site internet
peinture sculpture photographie une
sélection d'oeuvres différentes à
découvrir à la salle d'exposition de
guyancourt leur point commun ce sont
tous des artistes du territoire choisi
par un jury de professionnels art talent
met à l'honneur les talents locaux
nicolas landry pour les images
[Musique]
et
c'est quelque chose d'un peu
apocalyptique où les gens les routes
vont nulle part j'avais envie d'un peu
d'exprimer sa une société où il reste
quelques éléments de marketing avec des
marques qui sont un peu me présente vous
tout est un peu sale tout est un peu
délavé
comme s'ils s'étaient passé quelque
chose mais les gens continuent leur vie
dans cette ville c'est un petit peu ce
que je voulais a présenté avec beaucoup
d'influencé bien sûr de science fiction
de films futuristes de divers dystopie
d'où le nom de l'oeuvre dystopia une
ville futuriste créé à partir de cartons
de circuits imprimés ou de plastique un
univers foisonnant imaginé par kg sommes
plusieurs mois de travail pour cet
habitant de guyancourt avec art talent
la ville lui donne l'opportunité
d'exposer avec d'autres artistes du
territoire
c'est notre troisième édition c'est un
concours d'art en direction des artistes
locaux professionnels et bien sûr
amateurs c'est vraiment divers
complètement toutes les esthétiques donc
à la sculpture la peinture la
photographie un mélange de techniques et
d'émotion des paysages épurés du désert
de l'invité d'honneur francis tac aux
créatures surréalistes d'arnaud shoot
c'est chamlal c'est une
photo fait à la base de farine qui
ensuite sur un portrait farine je le met
en mode miroir et on obtient une ce que
j'appelle des bestioles
je veux que chacun puisse partir un
petit peu là où il a envie d'aller avec
cette bestiole là je l'imaginé quelque
part ou imaginez juste de l'imaginer
savoir ce qu'elle représente une
sélection d'oeuvres à découvrir jusqu'au
29 avril
différents ateliers rencontres avec les
artistes sont prévues tout le moins
[Musique]
certains vont encore partir à la chasse
aux oeufs ce week end d'autres vont
pouvoir découvrir ce qui a un citoyen et
même un écocitoyen mélanie le
rendez-vous des juniors de cette semaine
se passe à magny les hameaux
et oui en une journée les enfants vont
pouvoir être un enquêteur sur une scène
de crime dessiner autour des droits des
enfants à prendre des premiers secours
save et ses premiers gestes qu'on peut
faire quand une personne un accident ou
se blessent cette journée éco citoyenne
c'est le temps fort la conclusion de la
semaine de la citoyenneté qu'a eu lieu
dans les écoles et les centres de
loisirs de la ville en novembre 2017
mais aussi tout au long de l'année
c'est important de travailler là-dessus
avec les enfants parce que c'est tout
petit qu'ils apprennent hisser les
citoyens de demain donc il faut aller
les faire travailler sur le thème de la
citoyenneté c'est la finalité de tout ce
travail qui a eu depuis pratiquement la
rentrée des classes
depuis le début de l'année scolaire en
fait et plusieurs manifestations sont
prévues avec notamment la gendarmerie de
magny les hameaux la sécurité routière
les jeunes sapeurs-pompiers donc
difficile un petit petit et tout le
monde et il ya une particularité aussi
cette année
et oui les mais nico ne seront pas
seulement des citoyens ils seront des
éco citoyens
plusieurs ateliers ateliers ludiques
sont proposées on pourra recharger son
téléphone portable en pédalant ils vont
être aussi sensibiliser à leurs droits
et leurs devoirs et ils vont pouvoir
partager un pique nique écocitoyen
écouter les habitants amènent leur
dessert la ville fournit tout enfin le
lent très lent
enfin tous les plats le matériel est il
le but c'est qu'il y ait zéro déchet et
donc pas lambada d'emballage pas de
plats pas de vaisselle jetable de quoi
laisser l'estaminet café aussi propre
lorsqu'on est arrivé la journée
écocitoyenne débute à 10 heures à 10
heures du côté du gymnase auguste
delaune et tout le programme est à
retrouver sur le site internet de la
commune qu'est nichée pas si vous voyez
lecture et qu'ils ont tellement même
sensible à la démarche du zéro déchet le
pique nique me tenterait bien je pense
merci en tout cas mélanie nous a parlé
de cette journée éco citoyenne
on le rappelle se déroule ce samedi 7
avril et on passe maintenant à notre
agenda avec encore deux rendez vous à
noter
[Musique]
ce samedi 7 avril aux clayes-sous-bois
ce sera le carnaval des couleurs rendez
vous dès 14 heures 30 sur le parvis de
la mairie pour une animation colorée
tout l'après midi
et surtout n'oubliez pas votre plus beau
déguisement et toute la journée du 7
avril également ce sera les universités
du goût à la ferme de gally de
saint-cyr-l'ecole plusieurs conférences
et débats sur le thème la mémoire et le
goût mais aussi des échanges libres et
gourmand rendez vous dès 9h30 se tut
loisirs est maintenant terminé merci de
nous avoir suivis nous espérons que vous
avez fait le plein d'idées sorties en
famille ou entre amis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
et d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]
oh